- Storing bread in the
refrigerator delays drying
and the growth of mold,
but increase the rate at
which the bread loses flavor.
So that already felt a little bit strange,
especially right around here.
But let's think about
why it feels strange.
So what's the subject?
The subject is storing
bread in the refrigerator.
It is singular.
It is a singular action.
The singular action of storing
bread in the refrigerator.
This right over here is singular.
We have a singular subject.
And then we see it right
over here, where later on,
and once again, the word
delays isn't up for debate.
They didn't underline this
as a potential error place.
This is a singular
version of the verb delay.
So this right over here is also singular.
So this verb right over here,
this singular verb agrees
with the singular subject.
Let me do that same magenta color.
If you have a singular subject,
then you should have a singular verb.
So this makes sense.
Storing bread in the refrigerator
delays drying and the growth of mold.
But then over here we say "but increase."
Increase?
This is the plural form of the verb,
so this really should be
"increases" to make it singular.
To give it the singular form of the word.
For this verb to agree
with the singular subject,
it needs to be "but increases" the rate
at which the bread loses flavor.
So the error is definitely
where we suspected.
It's in this part of the sentence.